hier leute leute leute leute leute bitte
bitte bisschen Ruhe bisschen Ruhe danke
bitte es geht hier schließlich um die
Zukunft unseres beliebten Gasthofs zum
güldenen Bären in unter uns Hausen der steht
ja jetzt schon seit einigen Monaten leer und
ich weiß jetzt auch nicht was dagegenpricht
ein paar geflüchtete da unterzubringen Sch
also ich denke keiner von uns ist pauschal
gegen Flüchtlinge ich ich persönlich finde ja
der kratzige Bär der wäre ideal für Ukrainer die
sollen ja sehr sauber sein danke Renate aber ich
habe mich auch bemüht aber die Ukrainer sind alle
schade also sind alle an andere Kommunen vergeben
und deswegen werden jetzt dann bald 4 Menschen
aus Syrien und Afghanistan ganz to Fremde in der
eigenen Stadt das ist doch was da rauskommen oder
nicht Rüdiger Rüdiger wir sind 6000 es kommen 44
wir sind also mehr ja sie sie kennen mich als
besonderen Zeitgenossen und als solcher gebe
ich zu bedenken dass die afghanische Population
dazu neigt sich explosionsartig zu vermehren so
laut einer Studie neun Babys auf einmal Herbert
bei dem Post glaube ich ging es um afghanische
Windhunde Hunde ja ach ja Hunde mag ich ich denke
keiner von uns ist pauschal gegen Afghanen aber
müssen es denn unbedingt Menschen sein warum
machen wir den ranzigen Bär nicht zu einem
Tierheim für afghanische Windhunde ja unter
uns Hausen für Hunde in Not das ist eine gute
das ist eine gute Idee leute Leute Leute der
Besitzer des Gasthofes hat ganz klar gemacht
dass er geflüchteten eine Herberge bieten will
der möchte nur eins der möchte mit Zimmern Geld
verdienen so und das nennt sich dann hotellier
also so ein leidenschaftlicher hotellier oder ein
Gastgeber das sieht für mich anders aus wenn man
mich fragt darf ich an der Stelle einhaken sind
wir uns überhaupt sicher ob unser idyllisches
unter uns Hausen der die richtige Umgebung ist
für diese Art von Menschen ich meine die kommen
doch aus derbom Städten und hier ist es schön
ja auch mit der Natur genau und da wohnen die
alle marodierenden Bären und dann bleiben noch
die die Touristen Weg ja aber das Hotel steht
ja jetzt leer weil keine Touristen kommen ja
aber dann kommen noch erst recht keine mehr ja
und zudem ich meine kennen den diese Menschen
unsere Probleme mit der Infrastruktur wir haben
doch nicht mal mehr ein Bäcker die Leute sind zu
Fuß aus Afghanistan hierher geflüchtet es gibt
Grund zu der Annahme dass sie es auch bis zum
backsshop in oberunshausen schaffen vielleicht
sind die ja nicht nur geflüchtet sondern auch
handwerklich begabt oder so als bcker oder so
ja soll das bedeuten wenn ich jetzt noch Bäcker
werden wollen würde und und dann ist der Job
gleich weg oder was aber du bist doch Zahnarzt
Herbert bitte Bürgermeister wir wissen doch gar
nicht was da kommt ja das können ja 43 gute sein
und ein schlechter Renate Renate wir haben jetzt
bei uns gemeldet 23 schwangere Frauen da wissen
wir ja auch nicht was daraus was willst den
Du damit jetzt sagen es war nur ein Beispiel
ja also versteht mich nicht falsch ja ich habe
grundsätzlich nichts wenn geflüchtete in unserem
Hotel unterkommen ja aber wenn wenn die jetzt
mal Hand aufs Herz wenn die wochenlang in dem
Zimmer sind ja da belegt doch eine Studie dass
die irgendwann einmal rauskommen zum Marktplatz
ja und dann sitzen die alle auf dem Marktplatz
vom eiscaffe Venezia und der shakomo der hat
keine Pistazie mehr weil 44 Flüchtlinge
die weggeschlabbert haben so sieht's aus
also gut Rüdiger ich rede mit dem dcomo wegen dem
Pistazieneis ja was ist mit strazatella also gut
auch wegen strazateller darf ich fragen ob sie das
schlumpfeis absichtlich nicht erwähnt haben wir
werden für jede Sorte eine Lösung finden das ist
ja das Problem ihr wollt also keine [Musik] Lösung
also ich glaube ich spreche im Namen aller wenn
ich sage das war der vernünftigste Vorschlag ja
mein Gott also gut also gut dann kümmere ich
mich jetzt um keine Lösung ja geht doch ja her
wir haben was vergessen was denn na das Abo und
die Glocke was dann dann war das hier alles ganz
umsonst ich fürchte ja vielleicht wissen unsere
Zuschauer ja auch selbst wo sie abonnieren können
das jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr
klug